[Music]
good morning we apologize for being a
little late but as you might expect we
had a big turnout at the corporation
meeting and that's a conclusion of it
everyone had wanted to come up and say
hello and congratulate our new
president-elect so it took us a little
more time to get down here then then we
expected so we we appreciate your
patience I'm Dana Mead the chairman of
the MIT corporation season seated here
to my right in to your left
our first Jerry Friedman Institute
professor Nobel laureate who chaired the
faculty Advisory Committee in the search
for the new president the faculty
Advisory Committee was composed of 18
distinguished faculty cutting across
nearly every discipline in the Institute
as well as a large representation of
each rank and age group in the Institute
highly distinguished group sitting next
to him is Rafael bras who is the chair
of the MIT faculty it was instrumental
in working with Jerry and putting to the
faculty Advisory Committee together and
in the work that they did seated next to
Rafael is Jim Ciampi who chaired the
Corporation Committee on the presidency
which is just a very long and fancy name
for the search committee of the
corporation and I should say that one of
the major features of this search was
the fact that our faculty Advisory
Committee and our corporation committee
worked jointly joined-at-the-hip
throughout
you jointly and the like and when you
get into questions were certainly
willing to to cover that this morning
the corporation met and on
recommendation of the Executive
Committee of the corporation unanimously
elected professor Susan Hockfield is
currently the Provost of Yale University
as mi t--'s 16th president Susan is here
she's going to say a few words but
before I invite her to the podium let me
introduce her husband Tom Byrne and her
daughter Elizabeth who've joined us
today and with that and no further
remarks by me Susan would you like to
come up and say a few words please hello
friends I'm incredibly excited to be
here I'm deeply honored to have been
selected as mi t--'s 16th president as a
scientist I've always regarded MIT as a
beacon projecting an incredibly bright
light that has illuminated the path of
discovery and innovation for the entire
world and I know that I'm only one of
countless people who have been inspired
and at times certainly awed by MIT
strengths along the entire continuum of
scholarship from the most fundamental
basic research into the nature of our
world to the most advanced applications
and technologies it is of course the
mission of every University to produce
and disseminate knowledge and yet MIT
advances both parts of this mission at
an astonishing rate discoveries and
innovations have poured forth from the
Institute and a staggering torrent from
engineering and science to be sure but
just as impressively
from economics business the arts the
social sciences and the humanities now
as you might imagine over the last
several weeks I have become increasingly
attuned to any mention of
my tea and perhaps not surprisingly
hardly a day has gone by without news of
some MIT discovery some inventions some
new program coming to my attention mi
t--'s remarkable history of discovery
and invention alone might well have been
enough to draw me here but over these
last few months I've discovered another
critically important feature of this
institutions character and it's
something that speaks to the values and
ideals that seem to be the very
foundation of this place for my very
first conversations in the search
process I kept hearing about three of mi
t--'s central values true the pursuit of
truth integrity and the great
meritocracy I heard this from trustees I
heard it from faculty I heard it from
students and I heard it from staff
members and what I heard told me that
this was a place whose values closely
mirrored my own a place whose mission I
could truly embrace and a place where
Tom Elizabeth and I could really feel at
home I would guess that many of you are
wondering how I imagined the future for
MIT and I have to reassure everyone that
I am not planning to bring a kennel of
Yale Bulldogs or a truck full of Yale
paraphernalia to this campus what I
believe in is building strength on
strength each of MIT schools and
activities must continue to be strong
and distinctive and we must continue to
look for opportunities to amplify these
strengths through collaboration through
shared vision and through shared work my
overarching goal is to help MIT to be an
even greater MIT to become even better
at education at research and that
invention part of this goal will be met
by ensuring that anyone who has the
extraordinary talents and ambition to
make the most of what MIT has to offer
has a fair chance to join this community
also I'll do everything I can to
maintain mi t--'s leadership in setting
the agenda for national policy and
research and education as well as to
build bridges with academic centers and
other nations what do I want to see in
an mi t--'s future put quite simply I
want MIT to be the dream of every child
who wants to make the world a better
place and also the dream of every
engineer scientist scholar and artist
who draws inspiration from the idea of
working in a hotbed of innovation in
service to humanity I want to thank the
search committee and its advisory groups
of faculty and students for the gracious
and intelligent yet probing
conversations that we've had over the
course of the search process
I am truly looking forward to continuing
those conversations and to starting new
conversations with other people in the
community and in particular I thank Jim
Champi Jerry Friedman Dana Mead for
their steady help and the very many
insights that they have shared about
what Paul Gray calls this special place
I would be remiss indeed if I did not
seize this opportunity although I am
certain there will be many many more -
salute Chuck vest for his absolutely
extraordinary leadership both here at
MIT and on the national scene he's
brought forward a great number of key
initiatives and has forged important new
directions over the 14 years he has
served as mi t--'s president for his
work both for MIT and for the nation I
extend my personal thanks at this point
I've only just started to learn about
MIT this is now the season of going back
to school and it's time for me to do the
same I am looking forward to learning
from the students faculty staff and
alumni non alumni who will be my
teachers in the weeks and months ahead
I am simply incredibly excited to be
joining this learning community and I'm
honored beyond words to join this
Institute
tuition as mit president
[Applause]
I think MIT is an incredibly great place
and I want to help make it even greater
at this point I can't tell you where my
my attention will focus in the immediate
weeks and months but I have to say that
in the positions I've held at Yale I
have learned that there is extraordinary
insight that comes out of the community
and I will be talking to the people in
this community to learn from them where
they see the greatest opportunities to
be for MIT
thank you let me take this first
opportunity thanks Susan
for really assuming this great
opportunity and enroll to PR to be our
new leader just in the you know there
MIT I think MIT is greatest challenge is
how we to how we really continue our you
know our role of service and to some
degree greatness and what we've been
able to you know to achieve in the past
we stand at this point on an
extraordinarily I think good footing
particularly from the perspective of our
faculty of our of our students of the
quality of the people and the resources
that we you know that we have here and
the real question I think for the
futures how to take those those
capabilities and really extend them and
and build on them as susan has has said
this is a I think a particularly unique
time and I think the search committee
felt strongly both in mi t--'s
development again because we believe we
have great strengths but it's also
unique time the development of science
and where and where we are and how we
might leverage everything that we're
learning and on the verge of learning of
science that's the that's the great
opportunity that I think we see and also
how we take that learning not only in
the field of science but and move it
into into our other and along with our
other disciplines
the whole issue of collaboration among
the sciences and engineering mit is
poised with the terrific science and
engineering that it has to really take
advantage of the combination of the two
bringing engineering disciplines and
skills and analysis to the life sciences
and bringing the insights of the life
sciences back to engineering and we feel
that we are ideally poised and one of
the reasons we're so pleased to have a
scientist who understands this
combination and relationship in the
future because it is one of the big
challenges not just of MIT but of
science and engineering progress
throughout the world and in particularly
in the United States
so do you have any phones for questions
yeah it's a great question is I was Dean
at the graduate school at Yale for
almost five years and MIT has a
phenomenal graduate school with
absolutely terrific graduate students
and what might I bring for my experience
at Yale to these graduate students here
Yale had several challenges when I took
over the deanship there and you know
some of it is are the things that are
just always present in an academic
environment which is building further
strengths in the disciplines you have
and you know of course as president of
mighty this will be the preeminent you
know goal is to make sure that all of
the graduate programs are as strong as
they might be and have opportunities to
grow even stronger one of the things
that I worked on quite a bit at Yale was
building a real community for graduate
students and integrating the Graduate
School and graduate students more into
the entire university community I'm a
big believer in learning communities and
I will be looking for opportunities to
really develop those learning
communities even you know more strongly
than they currently exist at MIT there's
tremendous power and the people and you
know these are you know this is a place
that has extraordinary students
extraordinary faculty and helping to
build bridges so that they can talk to
one another and collaborate more I think
is always a good thing
yeah so how am I gonna interact with
undergraduates well I'm gonna start out
I've got a lot of learning ahead of me
and in the weeks and months ahead I'm
gonna meet with as many people as I can
while I was Dean of the Graduate School
I spent you know a lot of time just
going around meeting with people and I
find both formal interactions in groups
but informal interactions just walking
around campus to be a good way to get a
feeling for a place and I will do the
same here of course I know very little
about how life at MIT is actually
conducted and how work at MIT actually
gets done and so I will of course be
responsive to the cadence of life and
work here as I figure out ways to really
be in touch with the students the
faculty the staff just to reinforce
something and I think the tech is well
aware of it but early in this process I
sent a letter to the student leaders
both graduate and undergraduate and
asked them if they would assist us in
this search first by providing us with a
student's view both from the
undergraduate and graduate level of what
they felt were the major challenges for
MIT that the next president would have
to address and also how they viewed the
relationship of the leadership and
administration of the Institute with
them and in their lives they gave us a
terrific piece of paper and as you know
they had meetings and and talked to many
people it was such a good analysis we
felt that we asked the student
leadership to come in and appear before
the faculty Advisory Committee and the
search committee in person to discuss
their views and what they believed it
was it was a critical part of this
process in a very very important process
and as soon
as they were aware that we had made a
choice they contacted me since I was the
one that sent him the first letter and
volunteered to participate in the
transition and Susan will have an
opportunity to work with them and what
what their view of a successful
transition in other words relationships
with the student leadership student
clubs the living areas and so forth as
she begins to get acquainted with the
pulse and and the heartbeat of MIT from
the student level so we think this is
terrific because the students are
basically just picking up where they
left off in the search process and then
are going to create I think a very open
and good relationship with the new
president thank you I would only add I
had a chance to meet with some members
of this student advisory group and they
are you know simply an inspiring group
it was both undergraduate and graduate
students and you know no one you know
no group articulated you know the
mission the passion for MIT as acutely
as the students did so I'm very
impressed and I'm really looking forward
to further conversations with students
on this campus both graduate
undergraduate students early December is
my expected start day you know of course
you know a lot it can happen between now
and then but that's at what we're
anticipating by the end of the fall yeah
another question for mr. Mead what if
anything do you think it says about MIT
this one a woman to chew a life
scientists
well first we think it's terrific that
we have a woman and a life scientist I
think I read The Boston Globe if you
forgive me those you that don't work for
The Globe this morning and Marcella made
I think that point I should say however
that the selection was as much as
possible gender blind and was intended
that way it was conducted that way and
we selected the best person for this job
for MIT going forward incidentally
happens to be a very distinguished
scientist and a woman but that was not a
that was not the gender was not the
prime determination or even a
determination in this process I think
Jim would reinforce that and so would
Jerry so we're pleased but we didn't set
out and we did not conduct it in a way
to get us to that point we went as they
say in sports for the best athlete and
that's what we got
ever heard the question his life
scientists represent a shift there was
already a shift underway as you know
this is the first year and I believe in
the history of MIT that the research
dollars from NIH which is basically
comparing life sciences equals or
exceeds research dollars from Department
of Defense so the shift is already
taking place and it's very positive I
mean we're pursuing basically the
frontiers of science at the same time
that our engineering departments are
pursuing the frontiers in the areas in
which they they work one of Susan's
challenges and one which impressed us as
she talked about it was as i intimated
earlier to bring those two strengths
together and to make two and to equal
five which we think can happen here and
should happen it will not only benefit
MIT it'll benefit the nation and it'll
benefit humanity in the world because
there's huge leverage in these two areas
science and engineering and MIT is
ideally positioned to take advantage of
it as far as the life sciences all you
have to do is look around the campus you
can see brain and cognitive sciences
going up over there we've announced the
Broad Institute there are many other
signals and symbols of this shift but I
wouldn't overestimate the dramatic
nature of the shift it isn't it's
evolutionary it's founded on very strong
science and the ability to have a very
very strong faculty in each of these
areas which
we have thank you here is there one
question that we've just about run out
of time is one more menu
[Applause]